Quick version up front for the people
who just want the numbers against the
RTX 5060. The RX960 XT 16 gigabyte is
anywhere from 2% to 17% better at 1080p,
typically 10% it's the same to 22%
better at 1440p and it's sometimes worse
to up to 21% better at 4K with more
variability there. In RT, the 9060 XT
again ranges from significantly worse
than the RTX 5060 in Blackmouth Wukong
to can't divide by zero better in some
specific scenarios where the 5060 runs
out of VRAM. And to be clear, that would
also happen to the 960 XT 8 GB model,
which exists against itself. AMD's ray
tracing performance has continued to
show a significant improvement over the
last generation with it sometimes
equating the 7700 XT in RT scenarios.
And now that we have the important stuff
out of the way, a quick call back to a
few months ago. AMD, don't this up,
okay? And unfortunately, we're back to
that because AMD can't just launch a
product and shut the up. It has to
shove its own foot so deep into its
mouth that it comes out the other side.
Today, reviewing the 960 XT. And as
usual, it comes with its side of
executive marketing tweets, and we have
a lot of thoughts about that. There's
also a review in here, too. Before that,
this video is brought to you by Lean Lee
and the O1D Evo RGB case. The 11D Evo
RGB is an updated entry to the famed O11
lineup, retaining heavy support for fan
mounts, drive mount locations, and
flexibility on component mounting, such
as two options for the power supply. The
11D Evo RGB's dualchamber approach aims
to maximize cable storage on the
backside to streamline cable management.
Coupling this with a unique vertical GPU
mount to showcase the most expensive
part in most systems. Learn more at the
link in the description below. If you
want to jump to just the numbers and the
review and the benchmarks, that's fine.
We've got them. You can go to the
timestamp. But we need to talk about the
that AMD is doing as well
because we've done the same thing for
Nvidia. And that's the fair thing to do.
So AMD Frank Azor and guy who once bet
Twitter $10 that he'd have better supply
than Nvidia during peak COVID supply
shortages tweeted this recently. quote,
"Majority of gamers are still playing at
1080p and have no use for more than 8
gigabytes of memory. Most played games
worldwide are mostly esports games. We
wouldn't build it if there weren't a
market for it. If 8 gigabytes isn't
right for you, then there's 16 GB. Same
GPU, no compromise, just memory options.
And remember, we can trust AMD's opinion
on video games. And we raised the bar
yet again with our latest generation.
Personally, I've been playing some of my
favorite games on a new 900 X380 like
Hardware's Legacy, Far Cry 6, and Ashes
of the Singularity. And Ashes of the
Singularity. Back to Israel's tweet.
First of all, AMD is the king of
building things that have no market for
them. For example, the 2004 personal
internet communicator that it abandoned
in under two years. Bulldozer anti-lag
plus the first time because there's not
a market for getting vac banned. the
FX9370, the Radeon Pro Duo, Athlon
64X23800 plus E SFFF, Vega Frontier
Edition, Radeon 7, Vega 64, the AMD
RX6300 which exists, the Radeon 6500 XT
with PCIe Gen 4x4 somehow HD 2900 XT,
AMD Fusion Render Cloud, AMD Live
exclamation point, and
finally the AMD mountain bike. Oh no.
God, this is so
slow. How much travel did we
use? Shift. Shift. You
Shift. I wonder if it's going to
snap something like on the cassette or
the front rings. It's kind of wild that
the bash guard shattered like that.
And that is still the proudest I've ever
been of a product that GN killed
completely on its own. That might be the
only one that we were solely responsible
for the death of the
product, which is better than AMD being
responsible for the death of a person
riding it. Now, secondly, because I did
say first of all before all that, quote,
"Same GPU, no compromise." End quote.
While having half the VRAM is literally
a compromise. That is the definition of
a compromise. In the same way that
Corser's i500, which claimed no
compromises, was a compromise in its
entirety to the extent that they later
went through and removed all the no
compromise marketing language from the
website after the review. But rebranding
compromise as options is the type of
thing you'd put on your job application
to become the chief architect of
marketing. Okay, bad example, but this
is what AMD's best at. In June 2020, AMD
posted a blog post saying that 4 GB of
VRAM, quote, is evidently not enough for
today's games. End quote. January 2022,
AMD hides the blog post just ahead of
the launch of 4 GB GPU and then panicked
when it was discovered and unhid the
blog post. In 2020, after Nvidia's paid
8K marketing campaign, Azer tweets,
quote, I guess we'll scratch our 16K
gaming message. End quote. November
2020, Andy partners with Sony to slap a
gigantic 8K sticker on the PlayStation 5
boxes that it later removed the label
from. Also, November 2020, Frank Gazer
tweets about successfully buying his own
product in a market with a massive GPU
shortage, presumably to save $10 from a
bet. 2017, AMD posted a video that said,
"Poor Volulta," before having its ass
handed to it by Nvidia for the next
several generations. Also, years past,
the Fury is called the overclocker's
dream. 2016, now former AMD corporate
vice president Roy Taylor sat next to me
at the RX 480 launch event, looked over
my shoulder at the laptop where I was
looking up the Fury X specs and asked
why I was looking them up. I said I
couldn't remember if I had 4 GB of
memory. He said, "We'll never make that
mistake
again." Spoiler alert. That's the same
event where AMD gave us the tech demo of
the RX 480 running in Crossfire because
two of them beating a single GTX 1080 is
good marketing. And they had Ashes of
the Singularity running on one system
with the GPU benchmark and the other
system with the CPU benchmark. It's like
weaponized incompetent. The point is AMD
marketing continues to do AMD marketing
things and can't get out of its own way.
AMD is single-handedly keeping
podontists employed at this point with
how many emergency footmouth extraction
surgeries they have to perform. The
point is that an 8 gigabyte card should
not exist for $300 today. Not for
Nvidia, not for AMD. 8 GB cards do have
a place. He's right about that, but it's
not in $300 solutions. We had 8 gigabyte
cards for $200 years ago when AMD was
pushing the RX 480s and 580s on fire
sale. It's as if VRAM stopped advancing
and it's actively hurting gaming today.
You'll definitely notice this within a
few years, but you will also almost
certainly notice it even today. We've
already shown examples of it being a
problem with Nvidia, and it's the same
thing with AMD. If AMD wants to sell an
8 gigabyte esports card or whatever they
want to call it, it can do that. But do
it for the true low-end. Andy is right
back to Nvidia minus $50. AMD hasn't
realized that it has to invest in its
brand. Ways to do that would include
actually investing in it, like what
Intel's doing with ARC, where they
willingly take less money to establish
market share to try and eventually grow
it. Uh, another way to do it would be to
shut the up on Twitter. Get the
executives off of Twitter. It's not
helping. The investment is supposed to
go into products and getting market
share, not into oneupping Nvidia's
fuckups. like this is we're competing on
the wrong thing and giving out review
samples doesn't undo any of the
incompetence at play here. So anyway,
that is the rant. We do still have a
review and we're going to still go
through just the numbers like we always
do and talk about the numbers, but this
this
they I don't know why they both have to
suck so much right now. It's really
frustrating. Anyway, we've got a review
to get to, so let's do that. We'll start
with a quick thermal test to evaluate
how the Sapphire Pulse model does. These
lower-end cards sometimes get shafted
with poorly applied thermal solutions or
just mounting issues. In a 100%
rendering workload, the 960 XT GPU
temperature sensor climbed to about 56°
C steady state. That's completely
acceptable. The hotspot temperature was
79°, meaning that there is about a
23°ree delta between the two. The
highest we've ever seen for GPUs without
there being something enormously wrong
was in the 40s for a poorly installed
GPU cooler. And that was pretty wrong.
And this is why we pay attention to the
delta to begin with. In this instance,
23 is higher than we'd like to see, but
both numbers are well within the
tolerances, and we can thank the
relatively low power limit of this
particular GPU for that more than the
cooler. Memory temperatures ran warm at
85° C and an ambient of 21° C. We'd like
to see this cooler, at least a couple
degrees, because it leaves little room
for aging of the thermal interface
material and ramping internal case
temperatures for internal ambient, but
there's still enough room here that it's
okay overall considering the relatively
lower heat flux of this memory. We'll
evaluate this closer in our tearown
video that goes up later today
hopefully. One thing we noticed was the
bump right at the start. The fans took a
little bit to kick in and they didn't
hit until the GPU bounced off of what we
assume is the V BIOS temperature target.
You can see that in that bump at the
start where it's a 56 degree GPU
temperature and then after this it
aggressively gets cooled down and then
the fans uh slowly allow that to ramp
back to the temperature target. Next, we
checked the frequency log to ensure the
card was hitting the advertised clock
speed. In the same test where the GPU
leveled out at 56 degrees C, the core
frequency held at about 3130 MHz or so,
the advertised boost frequency is up to
3130 MHz according to AMD directly. So,
it's hitting that up two marker just
just barely at the high end of the up
two, which is 3130. We also ran a quick
acoustic test and our Hemiooic chamber
that we built. The RX960 XT Pulse ended
up being almost too quiet to get a good
read on it as it's near our noise floor.
The device measured at about 16 dBA
under full load and tested at 1 m
distance in the chamber shown by the
green line in this plot with some 9070
models and XTs for reference. The 9060
XT pulse ended up with a slight spike at
around 500 hertz which we've seen in the
other cards on this chart as well. And
then it had otherwise a relatively
gradual frequency fall-off later on in
the plot. Nothing jumped out at us here.
There's no weird behavior, and that's a
compliment for the Pulse. It's pretty
standard. The low power draw of the card
allows the fans to spin relatively
slowly, so it's likely that the other
fans in your system would be louder than
this GPU. Dragon Stoma 2 is up first.
Tested at 4K, the RX960 XT outperforms
the RTX 560 GPU. We are in unplayable
territory for these, but this is still a
useful tool to understand scaling across
resolutions. The RX960 XT 16 GB that
we're testing today leads the 5060 by 7%
here with both behind the former
flagship 2080 Ti GPU. The jump from the
9060 XD to the 9070 is huge at 79%
improved to the next card up from AMD.
AMD has a large performance gap between
these models. In between we can find the
7900 XT, the 7800 XT also from AMD and
the 6TN50 XT around the levels of the
7900 GRE as well. Nvidia competition
additionally includes the 5060Ti which
ran at 40 FPS average and outperformed
the 960 XT by 11%. At 1440p, the 960 XT
ran at a playable 65 FPS average with
lows proportionately spaced. The lows
for all the latest Nvidia and AMD cards
are indicative of consistent frame time
pacing for the game. The 65 FPS result
positions the 960 XT near the level of
the 7700 XT and the 3070 Ti, just below
the 5060 Ti. The 5060 Ti has a 7% lead
with the 9060 XT leading the 5060 nonTi
by 14%. The 9070 is of course
significantly better. It's also more
expensive at 106 FPS average to the 960
XT's 65 FPS average. So there remains a
large gap between these. Currently, that
gap is filled again by the 7800 XT, the
7900 GRE, the 6950 XT of prior
generations from AMD or the 3080, 4070,
and 5070 from Nvidia. So, these might be
some good starting places for used
options. At 1080p, the 9060 XT again
sits around the 3070 Ti and the 7700 XT
levels of performance. That positions it
ahead of the RTX 5060 by 13% with the
5060 Ti ahead of the 9060 XT by 8%. The
9070 improves to 134 FPS average from
the 86 FPS average of the 960 XT or 54%
with the 9070 XT improving by 68 1.5% to
145 FPS average just below the 5070Ti
and prior XTX flagship. Generationally
and by name only, which again has
shifted in meaning for both AMD and
Nvidia, the 960 XT improves on the 7600
by 42% and the 6600 XT by 48%. The 6600
XT launched at around $380, but was
available later in its life commonly for
$220 to $260. Final Fantasy 14 Dawn
Trail is up now, first at 4K. By frame
rate alone, the 960 XT is basically the
exact same product as the 6700 XT here.
The two are nearly identical in
performance. There's a VRAM difference,
obviously a specs difference, but how
they perform in reality is basically the
same. The original MSRP for the 6T700 XD
was around $480 and later in its life it
was commonly available for $300 to $350.
In other words, against only the launch
price, AMD has come down about $130 to
equal the performance of a card from 4
years ago. Checking sold listings of the
6700 XT on eBay since a used one would
be a viable alternative to these 960
XTs. You can find them from $250 or so
up to 400 with a lot of the listings in
the range of the upper 200s and lower
300s. The 4060Ti is about tied with the
960 XT with the 7700 XT slightly ahead.
The 5060 leads the 960 XT in this game
and benchmark. Part of our established
fact that AMD just generally struggles
in this particular test right now as
compared to Nvidia. In fact, even
Intel's B580 is outperforming the 960 XT
here, and it's cheaper. In this test,
the 960 XT just doesn't do that well
overall. The same was true of the 970
and the 970 XT in this testing. At
1440p, the 960 XT ran at 85 FPS average,
which has it equivalent to the 6T700 XT
from 2021, slightly below the B580,
although with better 0.1% lows, and just
barely ahead of the RTX 4060 Ti. This
game is one of Intel's more promising
for performance gains against the
incumbents and remains one of AMD's
weaker games. The 5060 leads the 9060 XT
by 2% for average FPS with lows
functionally the same. The RTX 560 Ti at
104 FPS average leads the 9060 XT by
22%. As we've seen in the past, AMD's
competitive performance in Final Fantasy
14, at least for Dawn Trail, the way we
benchmark it, just isn't as strong as in
other titles. Generationally, the 960 XT
leads the 6600 XT 63 FPS average by 36%,
the 6600 by 62%, and Nvidia's once most
common GPU, the GTX 10606 GB for this
model by 158%. Starfield is up next.
Sometimes people ask why we still test
this game. Well, we figured it makes
sense to benchmark a game nobody plays
with cards nobody wants to buy. AMD's
RX960 XT ran at 39 FPS average with lows
proportional to the average. None of the
Nvidia or AMD cards on this chart have
particularly strong or weak 1% or.1%
lows. The 5060 Ti 16 GB at 41 FPS
average outperforms the 960 XT 16 GB by
5%. Against the new 5060 that we bought
for 330, the 9060 XT leads by 18.8% in
average frame rate. lows scale along
with the average. We need to drop the
resolution though for more cards to
compare. Dropping to 1440p, the RX960 XT
ran at 62 FPS average and ended up
between the 5060Ti and the 3070 Ti. The
RTX 5060Ti 65 FPS average is
indistinguishably different from the
9060 XT from an experiential standpoint,
but technically ahead by 6%. Buying a
higherend card instead, like the 9070,
would improve the performance in this
title in that instance by 56% from 62
FPS average to 96. One of the cheapest
9070s in stock at the time of writing
this was $650. It's about $100 over
MSRP, which means that a $350 960 XT16
gigabyte, if you could find it at that
price, would achieve 64% of the
performance for 54% of the price. We
expect it'll be more than $350. Though
down the stack and against older
generations, the 960 XT distances itself
from the 6700 XT this time. Despite
similar performance in other games and
improves upon the 6600 XT by 63%, the
6600 by 94% and the 2060 by about the
same. Intel's B580 is similar to the RX
7600 in performance, but it suffers in
frame time consistency in this game. So,
it's just the average is that similar.
its experience would be noticeably worse
as a result. Tested at 1080p, the 960 XT
ran at 77 FPS average and maintained
consistent lows just like the other AMD
and Nvidia cards at its flanks. The
5060Ti runs just 4.7 FPS average higher
frame rate or a 6% advantage. Against
the 5060 nonTi, the 960 XT leads by 17%.
AMD's prior 7900 GRE, the 6T950 XT, and
Nvidia's new 5070 all end up ahead of
the 9060 XT in a similar clustered
ranking. Beyond that, there's the 9070,
which has an average FPS at 118 or 52%
ahead by MSRP, which the 9070 still
regularly is not. It's typically around
$650 what we're seeing right now. That'd
be a 52% performance gain for a 57%
price increase again by MSRP, but we
can't be sure where the 960XT will land
until launch. Resident Evil 4 is up now
at 4K. The 960 XT's 56 FPS average has
it about equal to the 5060 Ti. Neither
has a frame time consistency advantage
over the other. And all these metrics
are within variance. They're the same
result. The 3070Ti is just behind the
960 XT with the 7700 XT just ahead of
the 5060 Ti and the 9060 XT. and he
improves upon the 5060's 46 FPS average
by 20%, which is the same improvement
from the Intel A770. In this game, the
ARC GPUs do better for frame time
consistency than they have elsewhere.
The 960 XT is also 22% improved over the
Intel B580, although the B580 is
commonly cheaper. Generationally
noteworthy markers in this chart include
the 2060, the 6600, the 6600 XT, and the
7600. All of which would have a
significant improvement moving to the
960 XT or to a 5060Ti type of GPU. At
1440p, the 960 XT held a 106 FPS
average, putting it between the 5060 Ti
and the 3070 Ti. The 5060Ti is 6% ahead
in average frame rate. The 7700 XT and
the 4070 outperform both of these with
the 5070 notably ahead in both price and
performance. The 9070 again leaves a
large gap between it and the 960 XT with
a 62% improvement over the new card.
Versus the 5060, the 960 XT runs 17%
ahead, about the same as its uplift over
the 3070, the 4060Ti, and similar to the
6700 XT. Intel's B580 does okay to hang
on here, but isn't keeping up with the
newer 560 and 960 XT. It's getting
closer though, so we'll see what Intel
achieves in the next generation. Versus
older cards, users of the 2060 would see
an improvement of 127% to the 960 XT.
6600 owners would see the jump from 58
FPS to 106 FPS average, nearly doubling.
And 6600 XT users would also see a
meaningful uplift. Blacksmith, who call
up now, tested first at 4K, just for
scaling purposes. The 960 XT ran at 25.6
FPS average here. That's obviously not
playable. But let's look at the scaling
against the 5060. Performance is about
the same. The 5060 Ti is 22% ahead. So,
similar to what we've seen even in
higher frame rate scenarios, the 9070
improves on the 9060 XT by 61% here.
Let's move to a lower resolution. At
1440p, the 960 XT climbs to 49 FPS
average. That has it at about the same
level as the 7700 XT and the 3070 Ti.
The 560Ti is about 17% ahead of the 960
XT in this test with the 7800 XT
similarly ahead. As for the new 5060
that provides functionally the same
experience when not running into VRAMm
issues. The 3070 is around the same spot
as the 5060. The 9060 XT at least
improves over prior generation parts in
a meaningful way against the RX6600 XT's
29 FPS average. We saw a 66% improvement
versus Nvidia's popular 2060 from years
and years ago. The uplift is 94% from 25
fps average. 1080p puts the 9060 XT into
playable territory without any form of
upscaling. And with these quality
settings, the 960 XT ran at 71 FPS
average with lows where we'd expect
them. The 5060Ti's 81 FPS average has it
14% ahead of the 960 XT here with the
5060 66 FPS average giving up an 8% lead
to the 960 XT. This is a stronger title
for Nvidia even when rasterized. Intel's
B580 actually does okay for frame time
pacing this time, but ends up far down
the stack unfortunately with averages
and adjacent to the old 3060 and prior
generation 7600. It's just not
competitive here. The light 2 is up now.
4K isn't worth much time. First of all,
as we all know, the human eye can only
see 30 fps without running two of them
in SLI, which enables 60 fps visibility.
One of our viewers with glasses in the
last review pointed out that his
spectacles actually enable MFG4X,
multiplying the visible frame rate by a
further 2x on top of SLI eyeballs. All
of that is to say at 32 FPS average for
the 960 XTE, we're past perfection
anyway. Does that make any
sense and it's
perfect. It's completely perfect. The
5060 Ti outperforms the 960 XT by 20%
here. Similar to some of the other
tests, even in spite of the heavy
workload. It's why we include these
tests, though. for the heavy workload.
The 5060 is about the same. So, let's
move on. At 1440p, the 960 XT ran at 63
FPS average with good lows, but not any
better than any of its competitors. The
3070 is slightly ahead. And critically,
the B580 is actually about the same.
Intel does well in this one,
outperforming the 5060 in average and in
lows while being functionally equal to
the 960 XT's metrics. That's more
exciting than Nvidia or AMD here. But as
for Nvidia, the 5060 and 9060 XT would
feel about the same in play in this game
with the 5060Ti improving on the 960 XT
by 17%. Again, users of the now
venerable RTX3080 10 GB can feel pretty
good about their purchase because the
card is still hanging in there and
keeping pace with modern GPUs, not too
distant from the 9070. Speaking of, the
9070s uplift over the 960 XT is 68%,
putting them again in totally different
price and performance classes. Cyberpunk
2077 Phantom Liberty is up next. Tested
at 4K, the RX960 XT ran at about 30 FPS
average. So although there's only a 6%
lead for the 5060Ti, we're too
constrained in performance to have a
full picture yet. The 5060 fell notably
below the 960 XT here with the AMD
device holding a 21% advantage. Let's
see if that sticks at 1440p. At 1440p,
the 9060 XT ran at 64 FPS average and
landed between the 3070 Ti and the 5060
Ti. The lead over the 5060 non Ti drops
to 16.7% here, down from about 21% at
the less playable 4K. As for the 5060Ti,
its lead actually didn't change much.
It's at 7 12% ahead now from around 6%
previously. The 9060 XT is playable with
these settings. Moving to something like
a 5070 or a 9070 would obviously be a
huge jump up and would give some more
room for higher settings or just future
games or even mods in this game. But
that's also a big price jump. At 1080p,
the 960 XT pushed up to a 100 FPS
average. The 5060Ti's lead is now 8.8%.
So, we've seen it slowly increase its
advantage over the 9060 XT as resolution
has decreased. That's why we run the 4K
test even when the performance is too
limited to play because it can give some
interesting insights like this. As for
the 5060, the 9060 XT leads it by 12%
now. So, it has consistently dropped
from the 4K lead of about 21%.
Rateracing benchmarks are next. We'll
start with the worst case scenario for
everybody except for Nvidia, which is
Blackmith Wukong. First, at 4K upscaled,
the 960 XT ends up at the bottom of the
stack. AMD has at least improved its
rateracing performance over the 7000
series shown with the 7800 XT equaling
the 960 XD. But, it's not good enough to
contend with Nvidia, even if ignoring
the low frame rate at this resolution.
The 5060 runs a 52% higher average frame
rate than the 960 XT here. Let's move to
something that might actually run. At
1440p upscaled and ray traced to the 960
XT ran at 31 FPS average and landed just
ahead of the 2080 Super. That gives the
5060 nonTi and its 45 FPS average a lead
of 44%. Down from the 52% previously.
We'll see if that continues to the more
playable next resolution at 1080
upscaled. The 5060Ti ran at 54 FPS
average, leading the 960 XT by 72%. Even
the 9070 XT was technically below the
5060Ti, showing just how this particular
game remains undefeated for Nvidia. At
1080p upscaled, the 960 XT ran at 47 FPS
average. As always, for us, it's not
about the absolute frame rate, but
instead the relative frame rate. In a
relative sense, then the 5060 ends up
37% ahead of the 960 XD. In an absolute
sense, it's also just more playable at
the frame rate it's at. The interesting
part, though, is the shrinking of the
gap at lower resolutions here, possibly
because of how overrun it was. Andy's
GPU went from yielding a 52% advantage
to the 5060 to 44% at 1440p to 37% at
1080p upscaled. At this rate, maybe
they'll be at par at 144p or something.
The 5060 Ti ends up 60% ahead here with
the 9070 XT around the same level as
that. and he gets left behind in this
particular game with RT on. Dragon Stoma
2 with Ray tracing is up next. At 4K and
not upscaled, just at normal 4K, the 960
XT ran at 32 FPS average, basically
tying the 2080 Ti and just behind the
3070 Ti. The 5060Ti leads by 11% here
with the 9060 XT leading the 5060 9 Ti
by 6.4%. Better performers include the
5070 at 49 FPS average or 53% improved
and the 9070 at 76% improved. that
breaks rank from what we saw in most
rasterization tests. Of course, you
could keep scaling up, and we have
results for that as well. At 1440p with
RT and no upscaling, the 960 XT's 56 FPS
average puts it well into playable
territory with these settings. That has
the 7700 XT just barely ahead, but the
same from an experiential standpoint,
and the 3070 is behind. The lead over
the 5060's 50 FPS average is 12% for a
somewhat meaningful advantage. The
5060Ti has a similar lead of 10% over
the 960 XT. Compared to prior
generations, AMD has improved on its
architecture significantly and boosted
its RT performance meaningfully. This is
something we already saw in the 970 XT
review, but it continues at the lower
end. The 960 XT is a big jump over cards
like the 6600 XT and the 6600 when going
back a couple generations. At 1080p, the
960 XT 78 FPS average put it between the
7700 XT and the 5060Ti. The 5060Ti's
lead drops from 10% that we saw at 1440p
to just 5 a.5% at 1080p with the 960 XT
increasing the gap against the 5060 now
at 17% from 12% before. AMD is scaling
better in this test as resolution
decreases even with RT enabled. Moving
on to Dying Light 2 with ray tracing at
1440p upscale. The 9060 XT was at 51 FPS
average here and didn't have any issues
to speak of for frame time consistency.
that has it ahead of the 5060 by less
than two FPS, which wouldn't be
noticeable in real play. The 5060Ti's
lead is more meaningful at 17.8% over
the 960 XT, and overall, AMD is mostly
improving on its own past performances
here. It nearly hits the 7800 XT levels
with the 960 XT. So, at least that's an
improvement in RT. At 1080p, the 960
XT's 77 FPS average has it again at
about the level of the 7800 XT, just
ahead of the 7700 XT. The 5060Ti is
about 13% better in average frame rate
with the 9070 48% better than the 9060
XT. And similar to the 5070, AMD's 9060
XT is 7.8% ahead of the 5060 NDI here.
The B580 is down below that, though not
far below, and it has okay frame time
pacing this time around. The 3060Ti
remains a weirdly relevant comparison to
the 5060, which sort of makes it feel
like a 3060Ti super or something.
Resident Evil 4 ray traced is next,
first at 4K upscaled. The RX960 XT 16 GB
ran at 63 FPS average here, putting it
relatively close to the 5060Ti 67 FPS
average. The 5060Ti has a lead of just
7% here, which is good for the 960 XT.
The 5060 gives the 960 XT a 14%
advantage, so it's positioned better in
this test than in some of the other RT
benchmarks. Lows are also consistent and
proportional to the average, similar to
the flanking devices from Nvidia and
AMD. Intel actually also had an okay
overall performance here with a 50 FPS
average that begins to threaten the RTX
5060, though not the 960 XT. Intel is
mostly contending with the fact that
it's not consistently competitive
despite having improved this
significantly with Battle Mage. At 1440p
upscale than with RT, the 960 XT's 102
FPS average puts it just below the 7700
XT. The 5060 Ti is now 10% ahead, up
from its 7% lead at 4K. The 960 XT's 10
FPS lead over the 5060 nonTi also
reduces its advantage to 11% from 14%
previously. And finally, we'll show the
VRAMm issues on the 8 GB 5060. These
also apply to the 9060 XT 8 GB model,
which we'll test separately later. In
this ray tracing benchmark of Cyberpunk
2077 Phantom Liberty with 1080p RT
medium settings, the 5060 ran at 51 FPS
average, which sounds okay, but had
awful lows at 21 FPS for 0.1%. What's
important is looking at its neighbors.
The 7800 XT had nearly the same average,
but its lows indicated far more
consistent and less choppy frame time
pacing with the 43 FPS 0.1% result. The
960 XT held a 54 FPS average and had
well-timed consistent frames, resulting
in an actually good 1%.1% lows that
represents an overall consistent
experience. 8 GB cards struggle here
today already as shown on the 5060 and
3070 Ti. So, this is a now thing in some
of these games. To illustrate the point,
here's 4K with RT Medium. It's
ridiculous, but that is the point.
Despite struggling hard and overall
being stuttery with its 15 FPS average,
the 960 XT, to its credit, had
excellently paced frame times for its
average. Now, they're still bad. To be
clear, they are really bad, but at 13.7
and 13.6, they're paced better than they
should be. There's not a ton of data to
work with here for this frame rate. The
point though is that even this
experience is infinitely less than
what we observe in cards like the 3070
Ti, 3070, and 5060. All of which are so
variable from exceeding VRAM that the
numbers are meaningless. We really can't
tell them apart. They are just
unplayable in more ways than even the
9060 XT is here. So, this is an
illustration of VRAM limitations in real
time. Up next, we'll look at efficiency
benchmarks when capturing GPU power
consumption via the PCIe cables and the
PCIe slot combined. This is isolated
power draw to just the GPU. We're
representing efficiency in the form of
FPS per watt or frames per jewel if you
prefer, with higher being more
efficient. The product name also
contains the power drawn in this
specific test. In Starfield at 1440p,
the RX960 XT ended up slightly more
efficient than the 9070 XT, though
obviously with lower frame rate. The 960
XT pulled 169 watts in this test,
resulting in a 0.36 FPS per watt result.
The RTX 4060 has a much lower frame rate
that push it into lower graphics
settings if you wanted to keep it
relatively playable, but it's more
efficient and has lower overall power
draw. The 5060 was also behind the 9060
XT in frame rate, but also ahead in
efficiency as a result of a reduced
total power draw of 126 watts for its
frame rate. The 5060Ti pulled 145 watts
and had a higher frame rate than the 960
XT, allowing it to approach the top of
the charts with the 4060Ti. Both of
these are the 16 GB models, as is the
960 XT. F124 with RT is next and at 4K.
The RTX 5060 couldn't run this test
without major stuttering, so it's not on
the charts. The 960 XT had a 0.17 FPS
per watt result with the 5070 tying it
also at 0.17 FPS per watt, but with a
246 watt power draw. The 5060Ti pulled
176 watts here. The 960 XT is about the
same power consumption as the 5060Ti and
only slightly behind in frame rate as
this is one of AMD's stronger RT titles.
As a result, the efficiency is almost
the same. At 1080p with RT, the 9060 XT
continued to pull about 178 watts. Its
efficiency is better than that of the
9070 XT here, which is beyond the peak
point of the efficiency curve for the
volt frequency curve for the 970 XT. The
9060 XT is lower in frame rate, but its
lower power draw allows this efficiency
lead over its larger alternative. The
5060Ti ends up slightly more efficient
than the 960 XT with both pulling around
the same power and pushing a frame rate
within single digits of each other. This
is a good showing for AMD's new card.
We'll look at a worse one for AMD as
well. Final Fantasy 14 has poor overall
gaming performance for the 960 XT, which
means the 960 XT ends up lower down in
the chart. It's at 0.51 FPS per watt,
which at least has it improved on the
970 XT and the 7800 XT. The card is also
tied with Intel's B580, but related to
Nvidia, it's behind the 4060 and
significantly behind the 5060 Ti. All
right, so 8 GB cards can exist, but we
don't think they should at $300. And if
AMD wants to sell an OEM POS edition,
they're welcome to do that. We just
think that at this point, those should
be relegated to the true low-end devices
and should be distinct. Selling the
lower VRAMm alternative opens up the
door to less informed users, likely not
in our audience, getting tricked into
buying something worse than they're led
to believe. It also artificially
deflates the MSRP when people talk about
pricing. As far as performance versus
the RTX 5060, if we come back to that,
it's at least better in nearly all
instances. It's often around the levels
of the 3070 Ti tends to be between the
3070 and 3070 Ti in a lot of tests. The
16 GB 5060 Ti is currently $490 without
a combo and without open box on Newegg.
The 5060 Ti is up to 14% better in our
1080p tests. It's up to 17% better at
1440p. It's up to 22% better in 4K.
Really just depends on the test. And all
those numbers are for rasterized
specifically. RA tracing in games like
Blackmth, it really pulls away, but uh
it depends on the game. As for price
commentary, we don't really have any
yet. We need to see where the 960 XTs
land, and we'll do a pricing update
comparison once things settle down as
usual. So, I mean, that's it. We already
gave you the recap numbers in like the
first three sentences of this video. So,
you can check that if you want the quick
recap, but the charts are all throughout
the review. A lot of tests in here as
usual. It is a a fully featured review
from us. Uh, it's frustrating that AMD
can't just shut up and launch a product,
just like it's frustrating that Nvidia
has to play the games it plays to launch
a product. And I I don't know, man. I
just want to test GPUs and put the
numbers on charts. Um, it's way easier
to edit those videos, that's for sure.
But anyway, that's it for this one. Um,
you've got the numbers, you've got the
commentary, the pricing is what really
matters here. And at this point, we're
just we're I mean, I'm just kind of done
talking about MSRP pre-launch because we
get to post these things normally along
with launch or just before launch for
the GPUs. That means we don't really
know what the price is going to be. So,
what we're going to do is uh you've got
the numbers and we're going to look at
the prices as things solidify over the
coming weeks and then months and do
updates periodically. Might be hardware
news, might be standalone, just depends
on the depth. And that'll be where we
talk about the price commentary at this
point. Uh because anything else I mean
it's just like it's it's just
potentially misleading because the MSRPs
aren't holding and they're playing games
with VRAM to try and artificially
suppress the price that everyone's
talking about. Anyway, so that's it for
this one. Thanks for watching. Subscribe
for more. Go to store.gamesac.net or
patreon.com/gamersac to help us out
directly.